[Music]
[Applause]
Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated senior
writer he was there last night game four
and he joins us probably on very little
sleep if any sleep at all but Chris
thanks for getting up with us the lead
story should be the Nuggets advancing or
the possibility of LeBron James retiring
you know if you say anything but the
Nuggets advancing you've got a swath of
Middle America coming after you uh for
the disrespect that's been shown the
nuggets uh but when you have arguably
the greatest player of all time dropping
the most significant hints about his you
know future not including basketball
that has to be the main story and you
know I was in as you said Dan I was at
the arena last night I listened to
Darvin ham speak first then went over
the Nugget side to report out some stuff
on them but I was watching on my phone
the LeBron availability and from the
very beginning it was had a very strange
vibe to it because he was asked by
multiple reporters about next season you
know what the roster needed and a couple
of times he just wouldn't delve deep
into the future of this team the future
of himself and then at the very end of
that media availability kind of
unprompted he says I've got a lot to
think about this off season so you know
this was LeBron
wanting to put this out there wanting to
convey this message during this media
availability and look what it means is
certainly open to interpretation this
was probably the most draining season of
LeBron James's career when you factor in
his age when you factor in the mental
toll it had to have taken on him early
in the season to be going through all
the stuff with Russell Westbrook and the
dysfunction of the team and then you
have one of the one of the only major
injuries that LeBron suffered during his
career and then you have to factor in
the minutes he's playing that just
physically wears him down so it could
just be Dan that he was exhausted
physically and said and said what he
said because of that or
as we've often seen with LeBron
it could be a leverage play it could be
him you know putting this into the
universe to put pressure on the Lakers
to do exactly what he wants them to do
this off season to make the team better
or else he'll walk away yeah but didn't
we have this last year when he had a
leveraged play and he brought in Russell
Westbrook now it's Kyrie Irving
maybe I mean look one of the biggest
surprises
in recent memory for LeBron was that he
signed that extension last summer like
there was no need for him to sign that
extension like a one-year extension was
always going to be available to him I
understand the rationale by signing that
extension he took the topic of him
leaving in the off season off the table
and that you know in theory at the time
eliminated a potential distraction but
uh he didn't need to do it it was a
surprise that he did it he's always been
about leverage Dan whether it was in
Cleveland signing all those one-year
deals uh signing the short-term deal uh
with the Lakers uh more recently
um
this could just be that like you know
he's he's always been able to use his
power to get what he wants out of an
organization you're right it was Russell
Westbrook a couple of years ago that you
know absolutely you know was a disaster
but if LeBron feels like he can't do it
without a true reliable second star and
look we can debate the reliability of
Kyrie Irving all day long but if LeBron
feels he can't do it without Kyrie
Irving you know there's there's some
value in putting it into the universe
that he could walk away
yeah there's there's nothing that's
accidental with LeBron it's all
calculated
I just don't know what the angle is but
it certainly felt like
um
and there's frustration but he I think
deep down knew they weren't going to win
this series so he was going to have this
moment with the media and decided to you
know drop that off for everybody so he
stays in the news for whatever reason
but he wants to play with his son he's
made that very public
I don't know if he could take a year off
and then say you know what I'll be
re-energized and wait for my son to get
into the NBA
mini could I mean if he took a year off
and just spent it hanging out on USC's
campus watching brawny play and then
decided he wanted to come back in in 24
25 all 30 teams would would line up to
sign him
um but look at the end of the day Dan
LeBron is one of the most competitive
guys I've ever covered and he's coming
off a game that I thought was one of the
great games that he's played in his
career you know he ran out of gas in the
second half but 31 points in the first
half was remarkable you watch him in the
fourth quarter he's chasing Jamal Murray
around screens he's bodying up Nicola
jokic defensively he took back-to-back
charges in that fourth quarter against
Nicole yokic to give the Lakers a chance
at the end of that game no he's not 25
30 year old version of LeBron James but
he still
top 10 in the NBA top 15 in the NBA and
when he dials it up he can get right
back into that top five conversation I
just have a hard time seeing a player
like LeBron with his mentality walking
away when he's still able to play at the
high level that's why I think it's more
likely either a reaction to just an
exhausting mentally and physically
seasoned and a potential leverage play
to push the Lakers to do what he wants
Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated senior
writer uh the best basketball player in
the world is
it's jokic right now uh it's a Movable
Feast and a moving Target but you know I
don't hear too many of the pre-playoff
critics that said jokic couldn't get the
job done in the postseason
ringing that Bell anymore I mean the guy
at a triple has a eight has eight triple
doubles players aren't even over he has
eight triple doubles that's a record for
the postseason uh he's nowhere near as
bad defensively as as people have
suggested his rebounding on the
defensive glass was instrumental in
building that tent that lead in the
third quarter look at his numbers 13
points but 10 rebounds eight of them on
the defensive glass in that third
quarter he was he was just a giant in
this series and he's been a giant uh
this postseason and I've often taken had
issue with people that have said well he
doesn't get it done in the playoffs well
point two a year in the last three years
where he's had a team that was built to
win like this team is built to win you
know 2020 bubble year kind of weird you
know didn't get the job done then Jamal
Murray gets hurt before the 21 playoffs
is out all the 22 season this is the
first year of Nicola jokic's career that
he's had team that you look at and say
that team should win something that team
should win a championship and right now
what he's done this postseason just
powering through some really good teams
and putting on his best performances in
the biggest moments I don't know how you
can say anyone else but jokic is the
best player yeah I didn't think he was
the MVP Joker gave me what I thought he
would I thought Jamal Murray was the MVP
I thought he was the difference there
and
I mean I don't know if you agree and
maybe I'm not being fair to Joker but he
he didn't surprise me with his greatness
Jamal Murray surprised me or reminded me
of his greatness
that that's probably Jamal Murray was
kind of the breakout star of this series
and has been maybe the breakout star of
the postseason because you are reminded
that that Marie is is on this level it's
never been an All-Star but he's on this
level and you go back to the bubble year
in 2020 when he had that great duel with
Donovan Mitchell in the first round he
had some tremendous performances there
you're just reminded that he is a a
super high level guy yogic though
I I mean those shots Dan like where he's
just pulling the ball behind his head
and firing them up two times he did this
in game four he had LeBron draped all
over him in the first half and he made
it he had Anthony Davis draped all over
him in the second half and he made it
and look that's four or five times he's
he made shots like that in this series
and you're listening to Lebron after the
game like he literally tipped his cap to
Anthony Davis because of or to uh Dakota
okis for what he did uh you know with
those shots I mean he's he's remarkable
man what he's able to do offensively is
second to none
your uh Celtics on the brink
what happens if they get swept tonight
so
I'm a little
I'm a little a contrarian here on the
idea that Joe Missoula will get
scapegoated
um for starters I don't think it's
entirely Joe missoula's fault I think he
has been out coached by Eric bolstra in
this series but at the same time the
Celtics all year long have touted their
defensive strength and the guys in their
backcourt have believed that they are
the best defensive Wings in the league
Marcus Smart former Defensive Player of
the Year Derek White's second Team all
defense Jalen Brown two-way player and
they can't defend Jimmy Butler
one-on-one dead I was in Boston for game
two and look Jimmy admitted after the
game like the heat offense isn't all
that complicated it's him taking the
ball and deciding what he wants to do
with it they can't stop the point of
attack so when you have
you know purportedly great defensive
players that can't get stops I don't
know how you hang that all on on the
head coach the second part of this is
Joe Missoula is the closest thing that
Brad Stevens has to a protege you know
Brad Stevens hired him out of Fairmont
State and put him on his staff he
retained him or made sure imeiodoka
retained him when udoka took over as
head coach he elevated him or before he
kept him away from Utah which wanted to
hire him to be on will hardy staff then
he elevated him when the Press when the
time came with udoka uh going through
what he went through so Brad Stevens
believes in Joe Missoula and Brad
Stevens is a pretty loyal guy so I I I'm
not convinced that Joe Missoula is going
to be on the chopping block when this
series over I think more likely Dan you
see Joe Missoula half his bench staff
strengthened there has been a brain
drain in Boston over the last year
emeodoka leaves Joe mazul elevated but
Joe missoula's job isn't really replaced
will hardy leaves his job isn't replaced
Damon stottlemyer leaves his job isn't
replaced I mean with due respect to the
coaches the Celtics have there and
there's some very good ones there isn't
that former head coach on his staff
there isn't uh you know a depth of
experience on the front of the bench of
that staff I think more likely you see
Joe Missoula have Steven Silas added to
his staff maybe Frank Vogel gets added
to his staff you see coaches with
experience that are brought there to
help him because I think all things
considered at 34 years old Joe bazul has
been done a pretty good damn good job
this year taking over this team under
the circumstances that he had getting
them to the Conference Finals I'm not
convinced Joe Missoula is going to be
scapegoated for all this
well somebody's got to take the blame on
this this a team that's gone to the
finals before uh everybody wants to you
know Crown Jason Tatum as a top five
player and then he disappears uh Jalen
Brown does he want his own team I get it
this to me and I've said this many times
they feel like the best team the most
talented team and the deepest team in
the playoffs but
they might not even get to the NBA
finals it might get swept so somebody
got to take the heat here oh see what I
did I get it I
I get it I get it Dan that somebody that
there's a desire to blame somebody but
I I don't think you take out the coach
with the potential that Joe Missoula has
like Joe Missoula well is Jalen Brown
going to be there
he'll be there Jalen Jalen Brown is
going to be I think he'll be the highest
paid player in the NBA next season or or
this contract will make him the highest
paid player in the NBA when he
ultimately is able to sign he's going to
be there
um could they shake up the roster in
other ways maybe
um could they look to trade someone like
Marcus Smart maybe I mean there's a lot
of things the Celtics could potentially
do to to shake things up but I just I
just don't think Joe Missoula
I don't think firing him is the answer
and bringing in
Mike boodenholzer uh can you get it on
Nick nurse before it's too late I don't
know that that is necessarily the answer
their problems I do think Dan that
look we're gonna look back years from
now and wonder if it was absolutely
necessary to fire eme udoku like was it
necessary to do that because the Celtics
deemed his transgression
so bad that he was effectively fired he
was suspended with no promise of a
return and eventually parted ways at
mid-season why why do we know about what
what exactly happened here that the Nets
backed away and then Houston
you know hired him well it's different
it's different it's different than the
Net's backing away did not have as much
to do with what email udoka did as the
circumstances at that time remember they
let go Steve Nash that was right in the
middle of when Kyrie was going bonkers
and the Nets made a decision that you
know with all that going on with the how
polarizing Kyrie was in that moment it
wasn't the right call to bring in
emuodoka who would also bring some
backlash with them they just they made I
think more of a PR move than a
basketball coaching move but the rest
the league Dan because this has been
investigated uh by many teams over the
last eight to 12 months
um the rest of the league including the
league office where the NBA has no
problem with emiodoka coming back to
coach the rest of the league had no
problem with hiring email doka so it's
an open question one I don't think we
have an answer to maybe we will never
get an answer to that why email what
email doka did
was so significant that the Celtics
deemed it worthy to part ways with them
and was so insignificant that the Nets
were on the precipice of hiring him that
the Rockets were the first team to hire
him uh why there was such a disconnect
with with how that went down
thank you Chris as always we appreciate
your time
is there an opposite then of a Victory
lap because I took one last week and uh
is it a walk of shame for the Lakers no
no it's okay I took my okay I was with
you Caleb just short I I'm just with you
I mean I told you I'm I'm used to you
being wrong so it's not like I know I'm
disappointed or surprised
that's not very nice Dad no it's it's
not but you ask for it you could have
just said Thank you Dan and then I would
have talked to you next time
glutton for punishment all right that's
Chris Mannix senior writer Sports
illustrator